hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry
Captain America Civil War official
trailer number one has dropped I don't
think I can take the pressure and
there's so many comments so many tweets
and Facebook's and instagrams Ryan got
me out of bed for the same Huizar got to
check out this trailer Oh written by Jar
Jar payment yeah I don't know what
people happy about looking about how
[ __ ] epic this is gonna be for so
long now yeah I have no idea what's
going on to know that it's supposed to
be epic
taking care of his book
do you remember me your mom's name is
Sarah he used to wear newspapers in your
shoes you're a wanted man I don't do
that anymore what people who think you
did are coming right now I'm not
planning on taking you alive
boys got hops captain
wow we're great many people see you as a
hero
Liam hurts back there are some we prefer
the word vigilante
they've operated with unlimited power
and no supervision that's something the
world can no longer tolerate I know how
much [ __ ] is here
scared of this one please you only make
this worse you saying you'll arrest me
there will be consequences
yeah you seem a little defensive has
been a long day
the CAC step limitations we're gonna
better go back ask that's not the last
something we're punching your perfect
I just want to make sure you consider
all our options just people that shoot
at you usually want a few than me to ice
do you really want to punch your way out
what do we do who fight
it's like all the Avengers are back
Wow
sorry time you know I wouldn't do this
if I had any other choice but he's my
friend so wasn't no oh not bear
you pretty intense yes your hand for one
second Oh feel that uh yeah nipple
nipple chill nipple chill looks [ __ ]
sweet yeah it looks like that it looks
like they crashed Captain America into
the Bourne Ultimatum I still feel that
it's gonna be one hell of an epic
experience that what do I have that that
Bourne sort of like this is gonna be
really brutal and like harrowing but
also have a lot of like really dark
espionage drama yeah of course
you know it means Captain America it's
the Russo brothers again coming back so
yeah it's gonna have that scene the
dynamics between cap and Iron Man
forming in this antagonistic way this
rivalry way that's gonna be exciting to
watch because Chris Evans and Robert
Downey jr. have embodied the role for so
long now it would be so cool to see this
dynamic form where they're going
toe-to-toe with each other I kind of
wish it in a give away some stuff yeah I
mean when when I'm [ __ ]
what's-his-name roadie Bucky
but no when roadies enlighten when Iron
Man's holding Rhodey I kind of wish the
name sure that'd be dead he might not be
dead but it's like hinting at the fact
that it could I guess that's cool to
tease that but I'm still like at why
they did it but I would have rather they
didn't yeah exactly
they really did give a vibe that like I
it was an interesting trailer cuz it's
like this is a Captain America movie Oh
Iron Man's kind of a bad guy by the end
of the trailer it's like Iron Man looks
like he's the victim of all this you
know like they're ganging up on Iron Man
and fighting him it's a cool like
they're both super convicted so it's you
know yeah there whatever situation that
they're willing to do anything for I get
the sense and you know nothing that way
that they're not bad guys and so it's
interesting to see that this is the it's
conflicting I do so it's not like good
guy versus bad guys it's it's like two
good guys versus the whole time and it
doesn't look like it's gonna end in will
let's just team up and take down the one
common enemy like yeah like there's
gonna be a bigger thing to happen yeah
I'm curious as to as to what that'll be
it's a cool way to continue Iron Man in
the Marvel franchise because I know they
didn't officially sign on for
man for ya so this is a cool way to keep
Tony Stark going in the Marvel Universe
excluding the Avengers films yeah what
almost seems like if Avengers movies
sort of show Captain America Iron Man's
relationship at its best this is like
going to be the worst possible outcome
yeah it's like here are the worst sides
of their personalities clashing with
each other you know instead of the best
ones working together it's a cool
contrast it reminded me of something
with like the caliber of a born where
it's like you take the kind of dramatic
story but seriously and the action is
gritty cuz they always clash their comic
book movie into a different job and I
know Marvel movies tend to infuse like a
good amount of humor into their films I
don't think there will be no I'm kind of
hoping this doesn't do that normally I
like the saving grace of the humor of
the Marvel films it's like I want Tony
Stark to still make me laugh sure if
they could get like a morbid sense of
humor to this movie like yeah a little
bit of humor but not like if you make
the humor too too fun and helpful like
then it becomes a popcorn movie and like
the truer sense like you feel a good
action movie but if you give it sort of
a sardonic humor it might hit in a
different place yeah yeah you know it
might you might be able to have to break
the tension but still keep in the dark
spirit you know I gotta say I can't get
that last imagery off on mine were
[ __ ] there totally beating up Iron Man
yeah it's because willing to go to
remember length it take from our
standpoint the last time we really
kicked it with Bucky he was a total dick
you know he'd been brainwashed in all
sources yeah but we still don't know
what level he's at you know I can't we
actually trust him and he is fragile
yeah so it's it does get me wondering
like it's Captain America really
fighting for the right side I'm sure we
will find yeah I don't need your civil
war it's cool that William Hurd is back
after the Incredible Hulk oh yeah
they're finally acknowledging that he's
finally back yeah they're finally like
going you know what it was part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe second first
you're all been like scratching our
heads like was it what I could kind of
we didn't bother to retro called retcon
it so I guess kind of we just don't talk
about him a lot over dinner I'm pretty
sure we saw spider-man and black panther
and
and all in that trailer - did we yeah we
saw like all all the characters in that
trailer we saw ant-man
spider-man I'm gonna have to scrub this
then we saw Hatton May and we saw uh I
want Daniel Bruhl we saw vision at one
point and what take you know that okay
no I think black panther isn't this
trailer actually but yeah now that looks
like a sweet [ __ ] fella mom I'm
stoked for it like that is a film I want
to be there opening night for for sure
as of right now yeah I agree with you I
mean that always takes me a few days
these trailers to be like do I still
care but I mean that I I dug this on
that was [ __ ] awesome
it looks pretty rad yeah I love it
because when have they done that like
taking two heroes that were so invested
into and making them go toe-to-toe with
each other you know we've seen them take
like villains and make them go
toe-to-toe with each other but to have
two heroes do it that's something that I
haven't seen in cinema yet we've been so
invested in these two heroes yeah it's
gonna make for an awesome experience if
you're new to the channel you can click
this button to subscribe and become a
reject follow Jerry on this channel
reasons to jerry dank ass dubs to
playlists owned by said Jer bear Captain
America you teamcap know I just haven't
would you shut up we are filming we are
filming would you shut up we are filming
Shh
baby don't make me bust a cap in your
ass did it do